you talked about um your son oh my gosh
they're so terrific and haisha's 14 year
old son Atlas pays tribute to his late
mom for the first time since her death
calling her the brightest person he's
ever known could there be acting in
their future Atlas Hands Down loves it
wants it he's he's
hilarious the teen opens up to the Los
Angeles Inquisitor saying his mom always
knew how to solve a problem or help a
friend adding she always knew the right
thing to do I cannot put into words how
grateful I am or how much I miss her I
would say to anybody you know go for
what you feel truthfully in your life
and you will be rewarded a million fold
and shares Atlas with her ex James
Tupper who tells the publication Anne
and I were together for more than a
decade we have a beautiful son together
and in that time she was the very
definition of light in our lives always
bringing fun love and energy James added
that she will always be remembered in
their hearts and Minds
I'm so lucky I do I walk around with a
joyous experience I have two beautiful
children Ann is also Mom to 20 year old
son Homer whom she shares with her ex
Coleman lafoon I decided I'm going to be
the best mom and
dad oh that was a cue I know
and died in August following a car crash
in Los Angeles and Homer Who was
appointed administrator and personal
representative of his late mother's
estate in November announced earlier
this month that she had penned a second
Memoir at the time of her death a
follow-up to her 2001 Memoir call me
crazy I was trying to figure out the
tone of the book I was I was thinking in
very broad Strokes about the book and I
went up call me crazy that's what it is
because
I think I've been crazy even though I've
never been diagnosed call me crazy
details and Trauma from childhood abuse
struggles living in the public eye and
her past relationship with Ellen
DeGeneres whenever you're telling a
story like this you have to relive it
and I think that was not something that
I was expecting necessarily I knew it
would be a difficult Journey but I
didn't know quite how deep I would go
with it
and um
it's tough her new Memoir call me Anne
released on Tuesday covers similar
topics and Homer recently explained on
his mom's Instagram account that she
wrote the book to help others where she
could which Echoes what she told ET back
in 2001. it can make you crazy if you
don't talk about the pain in your life
so that is part of why I did this my
book is the truth of my life
but there are going to be a million
different opinions about why I'm telling
the truth so is it hard sure it's never
fun to hear that it's not just all good
you know
but I think it's easier it certainly
feels better to me
[Music]